restrictive nearest resolutions are
typically a recipe for Burnout so
focusing on what we can add to our
routine like the right supplements is a
much more sustainable approach and since
our gut health affects every other
system in our body focusing on
prebiotics probiotics and postbiotics
can be key if that sounds like the same
word rice let me break it down
probiotics are the good gut bacteria
prebiotics are the food that feed the
bacteria and postbiotics are the
beneficial byproducts from the bacteria
digesting their fuel I love rituals 3in1
symbiotic because you get a full gut
supporting routine in one capsule
including two of the most clinically
studied probiotic strains it's shell
stable so it's super easy to travel with
they're big on ingredient traceability
and they utilize a delayed release
capsule designed to ensure that the
probiotics make it to the colon to do
their job so if you're looking to
support your gut health this holiday
check out the link in my description for
40% off of your
order